[Music]
[Applause]
hey everybody its charlie we had a brand
new birds-of-prey secret trailer that
they dropped in front of the spider-man
far from home rerelease this one's in
Ukrainian because they have not released
it online so we only have a couple
versions floating around right now
so we'll break it down we're doing a
movie ticket giveaway all you have to do
to enter is be a subscriber and leave
your favorite Harley Quinn moment on the
video I know I just did a review of the
Joker movie so I'll explain what's going
on with the Joker movie with the Harley
Quinn birds-of-prey movie because some
of these new movies that are coming in
the next year or two are gonna be
connected to the larger Justice League
DC EU and some of them are not like in
the case of the Joker movie which is DC
black label completely separate things
so it sounds more confusing than it
actually is but what's going on with
this new footage is is that Spider Man
far from home was just re-released in
theaters with an extended cut by Sony
they added a couple extra minutes of
footage but in some places around the
world they were playing this special
fake-out birds-of-prey trailer made to
look like an itch chapter 2 trailer
Warner Brothers is also releasing it
chapter 2 in the next couple of weeks so
that's why they're putting this in front
of that Spider Man far from home
rerelease so red balloons start rising
up around the Warner Brothers logo from
the it movie and it starts to play the
it chapter to music that theme song for
penny wise making you feel long
comfortable but then when it seems like
it's going to reveal Pennywise the clown
you can even see his baggy pants through
the balloons here but then as it starts
to reveal the character it winds up
being Harley Quinn in one of her new
outfits from the birds of prey movie she
grabs her mouth from the comic books
swings it destroying a bunch of the
balloons and if you don't speak
ukrainian which a lot of you probably
don't what she's saying roughly
translates to screw off with all these
damn clowns already because Harley Quinn
is the Joker penny wise all very clown
specific characters clown me zazen
permeates all of their stories so her
saying screw off with all these damn
clowns already is a nice burn on penny
wise from it chapter two but it also has
something to do with the plot of the
birds of prey movie because get this the
official full title of the birds of prey
movie is birds of prey in the
fantabulous Emancipation of one Harley
Quinn as if Harley Quinn herself titled
her own movie which seems like a meta
thing that Harley Quinn
do but she doesn't break the fourth wall
quite as much as a character like
Deadpool does but it is meant to be a
fourth wall break joke where she's
slowly trying to emancipate herself from
the Joker this is a copy of Margot
Robbie's script in real life so just let
you know that ridiculous sounding title
is something that Harley Quinn came up
with entitled her own movie so a big
part of the movie is Harley Quinn
breaking up with the Jared Leto version
of the Joker from the previous films as
they've been in together those two
characters Harley Quinn and the Joker
have always had this weird codependent
relationship in the comics and in the
animated versions because technically
she did originate in Batman the Animated
Series cartoon and then became a comic
book character one of DC Comics few and
most successful popular comic book
characters that did not originate in the
comics if you're a big fan of the
character you probably already know that
she was created by Paul Dini there's
actually a character in the birds of
prey movie called officer Dini inside
the Gotham City Police Department based
on Paul Dini I don't think that he
himself is playing that character but he
also might have a cameo somewhere during
the movie for the basic premises because
Harley Quinn is a criminal and because
the little girl Cassandra came that the
birds of prey team is trying to save
from black mask are all either criminals
themselves or terrible people is
basically a group of anti heroes versus
the Gotham mob bosses so the Gotham City
Police Department don't want to lift a
finger to help them out while you're
criminals we arrest you on a regular
basis why should we bother to help you
out if nothing illegal is technically
happening so it's one of those weird
situations whereby they're trying to
save a little girl and in order to have
to do that they're the ones that are
breaking the law black mask who's the
villain of the film isn't technically
doing anything that's against the law so
the police can't really help them except
for Renee Montoya that kind of takes
pity on them because she's down and out
on her luck and the regular police don't
want to have anything to do with Harley
Quinn then you have Batman where you
would normally expect him to step in in
a situation like this he's dealing with
bigger problems so no one is really
willing to lift a finger to help these
female characters out so they have to
band together and that's where the girl
gang birds-of-prey forms I know you're
all asking you and McGregor playing
black masks how come he's not wearing
the black mask from the comics I'd be
willing to bet
something happens during the movie to
scar his face and by the end of it he
will go full comic-book black mask it's
funny seeing him be a villain in this
right after we saw him come out on stage
and announced the Star Wars obi-wan
Kenobi TV series because there's still a
big question about what's gonna happen
with the Jared Leto version of the Joker
in future DC films and we have the
joaquin phoenix Joker i'll talk about
continuity with all these films in just
a second but the other brand-new footage
in this is Huntress on her motorcycles
speeding through the city then whipping
her hood off using her handheld crossbow
from the comics Black Canary in an
alleyway being stopped by a mobster then
just turning around kicking his ass I
don't know if she's gonna be a
full-blown metahuman during the movie
but we'll find out pretty quickly when
they're released the next big trailer
but then you have you McGregor's black
mask inside his nightclub with Black
Canary singing onstage behind him just
like new 52 Black Canary being a
songstress the new 52 one was more of a
punk rocker but you can kind of see how
they're trying to adapt that within this
there's a scene of Cassandra Cain hiding
from mobsters inside this giant funhouse
fight scene where you see Harley Quinn
then facing off with a bunch of black
mask's gang members inside the funhouse
she throws her mallet into one of their
faces not sure why he's wearing a rabbit
themed mask but that's probably just to
hide his identity then Black Canary
Renee Montoya in the Huntress inside a
club during daylight hours getting ready
to fight this group you can see Huntress
in the background kicking the [ __ ] out
of this dude and Renee Montoya is the
one in the foreground clocking this dude
making blood spray all over the place
and even though you do see blood
spraying all over the place here it's
supposed to be a pg-13 movie
unlike Joaquin Phoenix's Joker movie
which is hard are and part of the DC
black label so just to explain the
timeline a little bit what's going on
with Jared Leto's Joker first so this
movie birds-of-prey takes place after
the events of Justice League after the
events of Suicide Squad so she's still
been with Joker that whole time and at
the beginning of the film it will be her
slowly breaking away from him you seen
all these pictures of her wheeling
around all these supplies they're doing
her twin laughing hyenas from the comics
bud and Lou so they're doing a whole
bunch of deep cuts from the Harley Quinn
comics that you haven't seen before in
the movies yet it's a bigger version of
the Batman the Animated Series episode
where she got pissed off at the Joker so
took off and then went to hang out with
poison ivy and they just went on a tear
through gotham city during the day till
batman got through to chill out just
having fun being Gotham City sirens even
though there might not be any poison ivy
in this movie but now the talk is is
that what will wind up happening is that
birds of prey is successful enough then
future sequels would explore the Gotham
City sirens team so that's probably
where you would get to poison ivy
eventually but a lot of core Batman
villains are gonna be tied up with Matt
Reeves
Robert Pattinson Batman movies that's
supposed to be a trilogy and they're
supposed to be adapting the long
Halloween in dark victory so that's
gonna mean a whole bunch of Batman
villains across those films some minor
some major so if you're wondering why
certain characters aren't in some of
these Batman character films like Harley
Quinn Joker movie the new Batman movies
it's just because they're trying to
distribute these all around and not all
the films are connected like Matt Reeves
Batman movie is supposed to be set
during the 90s and won't crossover with
this birds of prey franchise the new
Batman movies are kind of connected to
the Justice League DC EU movies but it's
more of a prequel so it's very very
loosely connected and you're not gonna
see those Justice League characters pop
up the birds of prey movie however is
set in present-day so it's more likely
that you would see those characters
crossover with the other Justice League
characters Harley Quinn just being the
most popular one so don't be surprised
if she continues to show up in other
people's films right now Jared Leto
still has films on his contract with
Warner Brothers for future DC movies but
there's been no talk of bringing him
back so he is still sort of status
pending still wide open to theory
crafting so it's probably gonna be a hot
minute before you see another version of
the Joker in present day crossing over
with other Justice League characters and
it might not be Jared Leto's Joker but
post all your theories in the comments
below and let me know what you think of
Harley Quinn and birds of praise so far
they're supposed to be another really
big trailer in the next week or two so
of course when that drops I will totally
make a video about it they're getting
ready to shoot James Gunn's Suicide
Squad reboot so there'll be some news
for that but it's gonna be a while
before we get any footage when we get
more details about that I'll do a new
video and also do a black Adam update
pretty soon too but I just posted my
non-spoilery Joker movie review you can
click here to watch that and you can
click here for that big Marvel phase 4
teaser from d23 thank you so much for
watching everybody stay awesome I'll see
you guys tonight
[Music]